foreign
hello everybody Welcome to an episode of
Genius talks
I don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
this is called I'm just using this mic
because the audio sounds a lot better
but
um yeah I just wanted to make a video
because I haven't made a video with just
myself in so long that this is this is
what I used to do remember for those of
you who have uh watched this channel for
years you probably already know that I
did videos like this where I would speak
into camera and I would just
talk my [ __ ] let's go but after a while
I decided to switch over to podcasting
I've talked about this before podcasting
was just something that was really fun
and it was something new and when I took
that chance I lost a lot of subscribers
and a lot of people told me to go [ __ ]
off and I'm fine but that's okay right
people didn't sign up for the podcast
and they thought that you know me
talking to the camera one-on-one was
going to be the [ __ ] well guess what
um yeah I kind of wanted to do it again
you know I've been dealing with
something for the past like
four or five years that I that I don't
really talk about and actually we're
going to talk about this on the podcast
upcoming up up coming up the [ __ ]
English baby coming up with uh Jason
Cheney and also Nick when we talk about
this idea of imposter syndrome and I
have
I've had this for so [ __ ] long
um
it's been kind of rough like you know
multiple times on this podcast or even
on this channel I've talked about my
anxiety I've talked about a lot of the
stuff that I've dealt with but
I've always been in this weird mind
state where I felt that I never deserved
anything that I've had no matter how
hard I've worked on it no matter how
much time and effort I put into things I
just
I never felt I deserved it any type of
success that I've had and I try to fool
myself I try to tell myself just
verbally like David you deserve this
[ __ ] like this is your [ __ ] this is this
is your time [ __ ] you that big
dick you know dang a dang
that's not how I feel though a majority
of the time I feel that
I'm just lucky to be able to do anything
that I have and that when people watch
my stuff it's only because
um I've somehow created a following by
an accident so I better not you know be
proud of anything that I've done because
I haven't done [ __ ] and I and I cycle
through this thought every [ __ ] day
and it's tough you know I've been
watching a lot of other people's content
where I specifically have been watching
this kid named La Russell and this young
man I I see this guy and how he speaks
what he does into existence and not
doesn't not only does he say how he
feels he actually puts the action behind
it and before I do anything or before I
even put out anything I'm the first
person to talk myself out of it and I've
been trying to figure out why for the
longest time and this imposter Center
thing is eating away at me I haven't
posted content outside of podcasts
because podcast is easy I get to talk to
somebody I get to bounce ideas off of
them and it's really fun and it helps a
lot of people out but when it comes to
my own content I get so scared to put
anything up because I'm like this isn't
perfect enough
this isn't good enough why do you get to
talk the way that you do why are you
saying these things Ben it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter social media is too hard
anyways you've moved past this and it
keeps and I keep coming back to grabbing
this camera buying new gear for it
setting it up and then I don't do
anything
and I'm sitting here wondering what it
is
right even when I put this video out
because I am going to put this video out
I'm not writing anything I'm just kind
of saying [ __ ] off the top of my head
just like a podcast but
I've come onto space to tell people you
have to believe in yourself and
sometimes I don't think I believe in my
own [ __ ] that I say sometimes I feel
like I'm trying to create another person
that'll inspire me so I say things that
I say to myself but sometimes I don't
believe I don't think that I'm special I
don't think I have a lot to offer but
for some reason I have a following for
some reason people watch these videos
you know over time I've lost a lot of
views and
I don't think I've ever
set this out loud
When My Views started dying I felt that
it made sense
I felt that the channel dying and you
know people going away from the channel
made me feel like okay now these numbers
match how I feel it inside
and it's been a weird [ __ ] Journey
one of the things that I have been doing
in the last like three or four years is
self-sabotage
I had been doing it so much I have been
sabotaging my career for the last three
years because once again I feel like I
don't deserve it
how weird is that
do you do that too are you just like me
or when success comes your way you
ignore it you don't give yourself praise
you don't tell yourself that you are
loved you don't tell yourself that what
you have done up into this point is a
result of your hard work simply because
you don't feel that you deserve any
[ __ ] success and that is the the my
every day for the past few years maybe
even longer I don't know that's why you
rarely ever see me self-promote if I
have to promote secret society if I have
to promote my matcha brand which I'm
really [ __ ] proud of we put so much
work into it and I won't promote it I
won't put it on my stories I won't put
it on my my Instagram I won't
foreign
I'm putting out this video only to say
that next year I have to be different
I can't keep telling myself I don't
deserve something and I've always in a
you know I've said it before a million
times over that one of my biggest fears
in life is that I will wake up one day
on my deathbed and I will say that I
wish I could have done more
and I have been convincing myself that
the things that I want in this life is
things that I I don't need
and I don't think that's the case
like I I want to create content
I want to be financially successful and
every all the financial success I've had
I feel like it's fallen into my lap
because I don't know God gave me this
ability to use my mouth to make money
wow they can't that that came out way
different than I thought I'm using my
mouth
I used my mouth to make
okay I'm not sucking dick yet
at all next year I am going to be a man
of confidence and I want people to who
watch this Channel and who follow me to
also be that person too let's really
just believe in ourselves
let's look in the mirror and look at
somebody that either we want to be or
appreciate the person that we are and
it's hard and I and I feel like this is
how it is for a lot of immigrant kids
because we're maybe put into a state of
should always be humble but sometimes
when you know for people like us when we
say we should be humble we also forget
that we also should be proud of the work
that we do we should be able to say hey
look I'm dope look at the [ __ ] that I've
done
and sometimes like for me all I do is
compare myself to people who are great
and I say I'm not them so I shouldn't
promote myself because if I'm not on
their level I am not deserving of this
praise and success and I think I'm just
tired of it I'm gonna figure this out
for next year I don't know what it is
and I don't know how many times I've
told you all that I'm coming back to
doing more content and then I disappear
and the reason why I've disappeared is
because every time I put out a video I
felt that
I was just
I wasn't good enough so here's the next
year everybody or maybe not even next
year maybe in a couple of days I'm not
going to have a set schedule for this
channel I'm just going to upload when I
upload but your boy has thoughts your
boy wants to create content again
and
I'm gonna have to work through this [ __ ]
it's been tough hey try some therapy out
[ __ ] I hope you guys have
enjoyed this journey I mean some of you
have watched me for 10 plus years and
you see me through all my stages in life
you've seen [ __ ] you know acne David
fat David uh before the LASIK surgery
David uh fit David uh boxing David
kickboxing David uh podcasting David
acting David Netflix David Sundance
David you've seen so many versions of me
and that was just me flipping through
things to find a reason to love myself
and I I'm I'm really in this space right
now where
I just want to be selfish all that love
and effort that I put into external
things I'm gonna put it all back into
myself
I am worthy I deserve this
the things that I make the things that I
create is a reflection of me
it's amazing it's dope
secret society is dope
the the genius brain collab I put out is
[ __ ] dope
and if things don't serve me if things
don't uplift me and my people around me
I'm cutting it all out
do you guys deal with imposter syndrome
let me know in the comments below
my name is David so and I'll see you all
next time
hate that sign up what did I used to say
what did I used to say it was a life is
always what you make it take what you
deserve
scoffer broke